I'm here with Nick Rogan of Ascension
and your move Ches welcome back to the
show it's always good to be back yeah
tell us a little bit more about what you
guys are doing with your move Ches I
know you're in Ferguson we up this is a
third year of the program a partnership
with ascension and the st. Louis chess
club and it keeps growing every year so
last year we did a fundraiser in the
spring and raised a lot of money to
expand the program not just in Ferguson
now but we're actually in Chicago and
moved it to Nashville have over 40
schools that were working with and
trying to get the kids to start playing
chess younger and younger younger as
part of their curricula so not just
after school but during the day and
hopefully having them fall in love with
it and play it throughout school and
throughout the rest of their life and
learn the lessons that they learn from
chess I now have a 15 month old son
what's the perfect age I'm sure you get
that all the time as I do what is the
perfect age to teach someone chess you
know I think as soon as you can walk and
talk to move around
we have kids as young as 1st and 2nd
grade and I'm sure you'll have a little
grandmaster by the age of 13
but you know the younger the better and
what we're seeing is the kids that start
younger learn more of their brains are
like sponges and they absorb all that
and and they take that love with them
from year to year as they advance in
school and I had one kid in the program
tell me that you know the the lessons
that he learns over the board apply just
as well to life about planning ahead
your decisions have consequences making
sure that your you're thinking far ahead
and and so I think the younger the
better yeah I agree
15 months is that about the right age
well here we see some shot some Fabiano
yeah we we had a great this year when we
did our fundraiser Bobby was so generous
with his time and Eric Hanson invar and
others and we actually auctioned off the
opportunity for the attendees to play
blitz against some of the world's
greatest grandmasters and and that was a
lot of fun and then Fabi did a I think a
four-way cyma with three grandmasters
and a national master which was a lot of
fun too and it was really an amazing
event we want to build on that and it's
not just raising money for the program
but also getting the kids to come and
and play with some of the grandmasters
and be in that atmosphere and be
inspired yeah and I understand that your
fundraiser this year has moved to the
fall it's an October 17 yeah
is anybody buy a ticket anybody could
buy a ticket and we'll have the online
registration and anybody could come
visit you can donate online and we we're
really excited I mean it's it's a
wonderful program and I think it's a
reflection of Rex Sinquefield commitment
to bringing chesta st. Louis it's the
10th anniversary of the Chess Club which
we're celebrating and st. Louis is
really not only the epicenter of chess
in the United States I think in the
globe and that's saying something and
that's because of Rex's vision and this
program wouldn't exist work not for the
Chess Club and Rex vision and his
inspiration for scholastic chest and so
I love that mission of trying to inspire
kids to play chess in school absolutely
and I love that Fabiano Khurana was so
generous with his time but today it
might be late looking like he's being a
little generous on the board which we
don't like as fabi fans what do you make
I mean I know you're a chess player
yourself are you who are you rooting for
here who do you thinks gonna win I'm
Rudy for Fabi just because I think it's
amazing that for the first time since
Bobby Fischer an American is playing for
the world championship I think the third
American ever with Marshall back in the
20s so I'm rooting for Fabi I think my
theory is he's not he's not playing his
a-list stuff right now he doesn't want
to show anything to Magnus who I'm sure
was gonna watch this game or the
tournament but I'm convinced it's gonna
be a historic match in the in the fall
with Magnus and I think as an American I
take enormous pride in that I think
hopefully it'll recreate some of that
atmosphere in the in 1972 when Bobby
Fischer won the World Championship and
create a little bit of chess mania here
in the US again I agree
huge favi fan and I know like many st.
Louis ins you're also a fan of verision
who's doing well so I am a huge fan var
is a great guy he he came to a
fundraiser that my 12th wife had for
Marygrove which is really sweet of him
he's been to all of our move events and
and is a wonderful player and I think if
he were to win it would be a pretty big
deal given that you have Wesley and you
have Fabi of naca all in this field you
have three super GM's and so if Bobby
can't pull it out I definitely think
VARs gonna be my choice love it version
of Kobe on the People's Choice and thank
you so much for bringing chess to more
young people
we're gold don't forget about that your
move fundraiser on October 17 thank you